ah ouais ah c'est un peu là ça fait 88
pour moi 89 pour moi
et là effectivement 88 c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait là le 89 est super bien
dessiné c'est impressionnant dans sa
région Matthieu de Goulaine est le
dernier rempart contre la déforestation
il nous emmène à la frontière de sa
forêt pour constater l'étendue des
dégâts
donc la nation on marche dans tes 50
hectares de forêt tout ça ça
t'appartient on peut voir une
biodiversité étonnante et donc c'est ces
hectares qui te permettent d'élever tes
papillons et je crois que tu voulais
nous montrer quelque chose oui alors
donc en fait on a racheté ces 50
hectares de forêt primaire qui sont
parmi les derniers hectares de forêt
préservés de la région il était
important qu'il y a quelqu'un qui les
conserve une autre projet de papillon
permet justement de conserver ces
hectares car sans cette forêt on
n'aurait pas toutes les espèces de
papillons qu'on peut élever
malheureusement d'un côté de la
propriété on voit que c'est entièrement
défricher et c'est un quelqu'un qui a
acheté 300 hectares et qui a coupé toute
la forêt donc maintenant il n'y a plus
que de l'herbe
ton objectif c'est peut-être de racheter
les parcelles de tes voisins pour
replanter reboiser alors effectivement
dans un premier temps c'est surtout de
protéger ce qui existe et c'est plus de
du côté gauche de la propriété où il y a
encore de la forêt qu'on aimerait dans
un premier temps acheter cette forêt
pour la préserver faire un ensemble plus
important parce que pour les animaux
c'est très important puis dans un
deuxième temps peut-être que si
l'occasion se présente de convertir des
pâturages en on entend les vaches
d'ailleurs dans le fond de convertir ces
pâturages en forêt mais ça va prendre du
temps et c'est un très gros
investissement c'est assez
impressionnant ça fait vraiment
frontière quoi ça ça s'arrête net d'un
côté la forêt tropicale la forêtière
j'ai de l'autre côté des champs des
pâturages et là on voit très bien
qu'aucune bête peut vivre à part des
bêtes d'élevage quoi non c'est à dire
que chez nous il y a 350 espèces de
papillons de jours qui volent
pratiquement en permanence là chez le
voisin ou là on s'est coupé s'il y a 30
espèces c'est vraiment le maximum donc
la diversité diminuée par par 10
donc finalement Matthieu à quoi ça sert
les papillons ben écoute les papillons
sont très utiles parce que ce sont les
marqueurs de biodiversité un endroit où
il y a beaucoup de papillons c'est un
endroit à protéger en priorité parce
qu'il y a non seulement les papillons
mais il y a des oiseaux et toute une
faune une flore évidemment très
importante et alors à quoi Tropicalia va
servir dans ton élevage ecoute
Tropicalia va faire venir ses papiers en
élevage et grâce à cette à ses commandes
de papillon je vais pouvoir maintenir
mon activité continuer employer mes
quatre personnes surtout à l'année
finalement Tropicalia aidera à conserver
tes 50 hectares de forêt exactement
Tropicalia sera un partenaire très très
important pour la conservation de cette
forêt
ça c'est l'éclosoir des grands papillons
donc nos plus grands papillons sont
déposés en chrysalide ici et donc
aujourd'hui il y a quelques
connaissances et certains de ces
papillons vont aller dans les aires de
vol et les papillons dont je n'ai pas
besoin parce qu'il y en a déjà assez
dans les aires de vol vont être relâchés
à l'extérieur de la serre tout ce qu'on
voit c'est des jeunes qui viennent
d'éclore qui viennent des Lore
[Musique]
donc il faut prendre délicatement chaque
papillon les uns après les autres
tu peux juste nous montrer comment tu
les attrapes pour ne pas que ça leur
fasse mal donc on les attrape en général
en prenant le corps comme ça l'idée
c'est d'éviter de prendre cette partie
des ailes donc il faut prendre des ailes
le plus près possible du corps comme ça
le papillon quand il essaie de se
débattre il peut absolument pas
s'allumer les ailes il ne s'abîme
absolument pas évidemment j'ai tendance
à garder plus de femelles que de mal et
les mâle tu les relâche et le mal à ce
moment-là si j'en ai pas besoin je vais
le relâcher
tout ce qu'on a derrière c'est ta forêt
et donc tu vas repeupler ta forêt en
papillon voilà tous les jours on lâche
quelques-uns de nos papillons depuis
cette année j’élève un papillon qui est
assez mythique alors vous pouvez lire le
chiffre sur l'aile du papillon ça fait
quoi ça fait 96 moi j'ai mis 89 de mon
côté
8 et 9 on est d'accord et si ça fait 98
c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle le 89 ou
le 98
pour moi 89 pour moi
et là effectivement 88 c'est à dire
qu'en fait là le 89 est super bien
dessiné de l'autre c'est impressionnant
il faut quand même dire aussi qu'à
partir du moment où elle est lâche
jusqu'à présent ils étaient protégés des
oiseaux et de différents prédateurs mais
à partir de maintenant ils vont être à
la merci de des oiseaux de lézard
d'autres insectes aussi qui attendent
que ça donc un certain nombre ne vivront
probablement pas longtemps sur 100
papillons qui sont lâchés il y en a
peut-être que quelques-uns qui qui
survivent mais c'est comme ça dans la
nature c'est tout à fait normal voilà je
pense qu'on a dû lâcher une cinquantaine
de papillons ce qui fait que
pratiquement tous les ans là entre 2000
et 5000 papillons dans la nature ah oui
d'accord donc c'est quand même pas mal
parce qu'on est les seuls à faire ça en
Équateur donc à vous repeupler vraiment
en fait la forêt en papillon quoi je
crois que la forêt autour de la serre
autour de l'élevage n'a jamais été aussi
riche en papillons depuis des années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grâce à son élevage Mathieu de Goulaine
protège les papillons et toutes les
biodiversité de ces 50 hectares de
forêts aujourd'hui il est possible
d'apercevoir dans cette zone de
l'équateur certains papillons qui
avaient disparu et tout ça grâce à ses
lâchés de papillons et indirectement
grâce à son élevage
[Musique]